and finally new rule someone must
explain why celebrities running for high
office is a recurring nightmare we
cannot seem to shake
the rock caitlyn jenner
matthew mcconaughey randy quaid they all
have suggested lately that when it comes
to running the country they have what it
takes
and they do malignant narcissism
did we all not just witness the
cautionary tale named
donald trump the last four years was a
warning not an inspiration
you were supposed to see that and think
i guess high-level government jobs
should go to people who've trained for
it and know what they're doing
i'm sure caitlyn jenner is a nice person
but as california governor
she would be in charge of the world's
fifth largest economy
based on her qualifications of being a
background character in a reality show
not about her
randy quaid who you will remember as
cousin eddie in the vacation movies and
as
guy rooting through your recycling bin
in real life
also says he might want to run our state
when did governing become the safety
school
for when the guest spots on chicago fire
dry up
we treat government like the lowest rung
of celebrity
rock stars movie stars tv stars
dancing with the stars magicians
congressmen
governing
governing is a difficult nuanced job
with people's lives and livelihoods
at stake perhaps you've noticed that
things in america have been a little
different these last five
months that's because there are people
back in charge who spent their formative
years
not on a sound stage but studying the
stuff you need to know
to be effective on the world stage
matthew mcconaughey is i'm sure also a
lovely person but when he says he's
considering a run for governor in texas
i must say that is not all right all
right all right
and i'm not saying that he and all these
candidates
haven't led lifetimes of glorious
achievement
the rock proved once and for all that
weight lifters can drive
matthew introduced lincoln's to stoners
and
caitlyn married the woman who married
the guy who offend defended o.j
and it's not that they are actors it's
that they're not
professionals in this other field called
government
this
this guy was a rock star but because he
was good in his
field of government that's not you
there's a
there's a thousand things
you have to know before taking office to
do it right
and i bet those people i mentioned who
are now in charge
they know the answers to questions that
will come up
they don't have to look it up or ask can
our celebrity friends
say the same could they tell us
oh i don't know what is budget
reconciliation
what are the three legs of our nuclear
triad what's tpp
what does the fed do where's chad
what agency is responsible for our
nuclear weapons what does the 14th
amendment say
who's the prime minister of india in the
event of another nuclear
standoff with russia or china describe
kennedy's strategy that got us out of
the cuban missile crisis
governing is not a job you can pick up
on the afternoon
of the inauguration you can't learn it
on the fly
you can't fix it in post putin's not on
a green screen
and he doesn't give a [ __ ] about your
million dollar smile
if he tells you at a summit that he'd
like to take belarus now
you have to know that's a country and
not his lunch order
no one has to tell joe biden what's in
the constitution he was in the room
when it was written
[Applause]
i'm sure the rock is a good guy and a
bright guy
and that is not enough not enough
and frankly the fact that he thinks he
can step into the single
hardest job in the world with no
preparation tells me one thing for sure
about his judgment
it's terrible
you need more proof kanye west thought
he could do it
the rock says he might be the right man
for the job because he believes he can
unite the country
you can't why because the blue states
and red states both like your stupid
movies
let me put it bluntly to you and all
these would-be showbiz candidates
you're not good enough you're not smart
enough and
dog on it it completely doesn't matter
that people like you
they like you now because you're an
entertainer and thus largely
uncontroversial
governing is the opposite if you think
you can unite the country
you're delusional a space alien attack
couldn't unite this country
the aliens would say take us to your
leader and 70
of republicans would drive them to
mar-a-lago
you